[Musique]
la fourmi veut pas donner son miam miam
la fourmi veut pas donner son miams
prêteuse c'est une vieille embêteuse
plutôt que des chrétiens
[Musique]
la famille veut pas donner son miam
ses parents avaient du pèse des
troupeaux de puissants Corrèze une
chaîne de fourmilière de blé des diables
[Musique]
les laves crécelle
business
mais elle ne veut pas montrer ses fesses
fesses alors pour bouffer quand même
elle va au buffet d'une vie d'elle elle
butine dans les cocktails
[Musique]
me prier dans une secte ça nourrit pas
son insecte je n'ai rien à manger c'est
un drame
[Musique]
trainer miam du frigerateur allez ne
faire [__] mais certains branches
[Musique]
la fourmi veut pas gagner son miam miam
moi j'en ai ras les antennes je vais
déglinguer la fontaine ce macho qui
n'aime pas les cignes
[Musique]